soutient d'ailleurs ce matin aux
professionnels de santé suspendu pour
non vaccination une manifestation qui a
lieu devant le siège de l'ap-hp à paris
un mois après l'entrée en vigueur de
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
personnels soignants quinze mille
d'entre eux ont été suspendus depuis le
15 septembre dernier selon le ministère
de la santé et pour plus de précision on
va retrouver tout de suite notre
reporter estelle farges
[Musique]
bonjour estelle alors quel est le mot
d'ordre de ce rassemblement
olivier tout simplement exiger la
réintégration des personnels de santé de
l'ap-hp suspendu car non vaccinés sur un
rassemblement à l'appel de l'usap cgt à
l'union syndicale de l'assistance
publique et des soignants qui compte non
seulement à dénoncer leur suspension
mais aussi est l'impact de cette mesure
sur les services de santé pour eux il
s'agit tout simplement d'une situation
paradoxale puisque d'un côté il y à des
personnels de santé qui souhaitent
conserver leur emploi et de l'autre une
loi à qui leur interdit de travailler
alors que les services manque de
personnel elle s'est en tout cas ce
qu'on a pu lire dans un communiqué de
l'usap cgt
[Musique]
et justement estelle on en sait un peu
plus maintenant sur le nombre de
soignants qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés
et oui magali sur les 2 2 millions de
professionnels de santé que compte le
pays il était un peu plus de 288 me
l'avoir reçue à n'avoir reçu aucune dose
au 15 septembre date de l'entrée en
vigueur de l'obligation vaccinale pour
les personnels soignants au 6 octobre
dernier ils n'étaient plus que 129000 à
ne pas être vaccinés de son côté le
ministère de la santé a fait état de
quinze mille suspension à ce qui
pourrait signifier que parmi les non
suspendues et les noms enfin les
suspendus et les non vaccinés incertains
sont en congé ou en arrêt maladie ou
alors qu'ils ont tout simplement
bénéficié d'une certaine tolérance de
leur établissement merci beaucoup et
celle pour toutes ces précisions vous
allez suivre pour nous ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui pour vrt france et estelle
farges donc en direct devant l'ap-hp à
paris